und hier in berlin ist es in diesen
momenten zu der räumung einer linken
szene kneipe gekommen und zwar die
szenekneipe sind die karte am
vergangenen wochenende wurden bei
protesten mehrere polizisten verletzt
heute steht also die räumung an um 9
sollte es losgehen und neuköllns
bezirksbürgermeister in hickel blickt
mit sorge auf die kommenden 24 stunden
und das wohl auch zu recht wie mein
kollege peter wilke weiß er ist für uns
jetzt dort in berliner köln wird er sagt
uns ganz wie es die aktuelle situation
janina aktuell sind die demonstranten
noch immer nicht vor dem syndikat sie
stehen weit entfernt weil die ganze
straße rund um das syndikat von der
polizei weiträumig abgesperrt wurden wir
können sehen hinter mir dort vorne
stehen ein paar demonstranten die sich
hier momentan eher sehr ruhig streiten
und werden von der polizei davon
abgehalten näher an die szenekneipe
heranzukommen
außerdem stehen auch noch viele
demonstranten die straße runter ganz auf
der anderen seite der kneipe und dorthin
ist es schon ein wenig lauter dort sind
vorhin auch farbbomben und
feuerwerkskörper gezündet worden
die kneipe selber befindet sich in der
mitte der straße da vorne wo wir die
herren in den gelben westen sehen können
dauert ungefähr darüber befindet sich
die kneipe und jetzt bei mir ist der
pressesprecher der berliner polizei
thilo kablitz der uns mehr zu der
situation hier vor ort sein kann
herr kablitz die demonstranten sind seit
gestern abend 20 uhr stand hier und
demonstrieren gegen die räumung wollen
die räumung verhindern was können sie
uns sagen was ist in der nacht passiert
die nacht war ja anfänglich ruhig ist an
sich mehrere hundert zusammengefunden
das dann in der spitze bis zu 1000
teilnehmerinnen und teilnehmern an
diesen versammlungen mir dann wurde es
emotionaler und dann kam es leider auch
dazu dass aggressionen sein weg seine
bahn gebrochen hat ihre bahn gebrochen
hat und kolleginnen und kollegen
angegriffen wurden mit steinen beworfen
und flaschen beworfen worden
darüber hinaus gab es noch in brand
setzen sachbeschädigung und weitere
straftaten so dass wir letzten endes 44
festnahmen durchgeführt haben und leider
auch sechs kolleginnen und kollegen zu
verzeichnen haben die verletzt wurden
jetzt gerade ist es da vorne die straße
runter in wieder zu ausschreitungen
die demonstranten haben teilweise auch
von krieg gesprochen
was können sie uns genau sagen die so
kam es jetzt ja geradezu der eskalation
was ist da passiert jetzt vor wenigen zu
9 uhr wollte ja der gerichtsvollzieher
das objekt betreten seinen beschluss
durchsetzen
dementsprechend kam es auch kurz davor
zuerst unmutsbekundungen die wurden dann
lauter bisschen beleidigen dann flogen
irgendwann auch die pyrotechnik die dann
auch abgebrannt wurde und auch steine
auf einsatzkräfte jetzt ist die lage
wieder ein bisschen ruhiger auch wenn
sie nach wie vor emotional ist wie man
im hintergrund hört dann die räumung hat
jetzt begonnen da sind einsatzkräfte in
ist in die karten gedruckt können sie
mir sagen mit wie vielen einsatzkräften
sind sie vor ort und was erwarten sie
für den tag wie wird diese räumung jetzt
ablaufen der gerichtsvollzieher hat ja
ein amtshilfeersuchen an uns gestellt
umgeben sein beschluss durchzusetzen um
diese schließung der szenekneipe
durchzusetzen
dafür sind wir mit insgesamt 700
einsatzkräften im einsatz nicht
ausschließlich dafür sondern auch für
all die versammlungen die sich drum
herum rannten die hier ihre meinung auf
die straße bringen wollen die ganz
einfach protestieren wollen dagegen die
schließung dieser szene kneipe